you bit of a sci-fi geek I want you tell
us what you like
what am i a geek for yeah my stuff tends
to be even geekier in a way then sci-fi
I'm obsessed with Tales from the Crypt
the old comic books and the old TV show
which is very nerdy I even got at
comic-con in California I got a couple
of my old comics signed by old cartoon
artists and what else i cartoon artists
and comic-book she's never goes that
together sorry oops what else am I I'm a
I'm a huge twin peaks' freak I've
actually considered they do a trip to
Oregon where you get to like go to all
the locations and do everything from the
old show I've been tempted to do that
multiple times and that's pretty that's
pretty geeky so I have my weird little
obsessions what kind of things people
who come and speak to hearing what your
autograph at the Comic Cons are scared
well this has been refreshing this is
this is the first con I've done since
before the show I just finished the
Secret Circle and before that it was all
about terminator mail show which you
know of course I love talking about I
loved that show so much and it's really
touching how years later everybody's
still kind of devastated that it was
canceled after two seasons because I was
devastated too but it's been nice to
have people to talk about Secret Circle
with and the films I've done especially
being here in in London a lot of
Europeans coming in a lot of the kind of
funky indie movies I've been doing if
have also been on the table so it's been
it's been great to have a variety of
stuff to talk about but I'd say mostly
Terminator and Secret Circle Terminator
there so what was it like stepping into
that obviously huge franchise no
amazingly well-known part like John
Connor is terrifying I was I was just
turned 19 when I got the part and you
know I grew up on terminator and was
John Connor was like you know a hero to
me as well and the idea of at that age
kind of taking that roll over and a lot
of people when I started really didn't
like me in the part and I think luckily
by the end of the second season come
around to like and enjoy what I was
doing but I just had the best time on
that show I think it was so well written
and
acted and I miss it you know still
Secret Circle obviously something else
you saying that people ask you about
this time as well and unfortunately it's
something that hasn't this is continuing
is it if it had it continued how would
you like to seen it got ahead
well we kind of had a vague idea that
the second season was going to be about
bringing in all these other members to
it so it would be a massive circle which
I was always exciting but kind of a how
does that idea work you know you have so
many actors in this show already but I
think it would have been really fun and
certainly for my character the idea was
that he was going to finally you know go
to the dark side a little bit because he
but that was kind of the idea that was
intended to happen in first season and
then with so many other storylines and
pressing there and it kind of got
shifted but I you know that was alluded
to in the season 1 finale and so I get
to just imagine in my head being very
scary on Secret Circle season 2 that
didn't happen and what else you were
going to mention the movies as well
things like kaboom obviously and it's
well you've written and directed and
starred in a film how many who yeah
which right now are in the process of
kind of doing a fully-realized more
budgeted I guess more of a kind of
mature view of this idea and story but
it stylistically a very different kind
of film so that was in production and
then halted for Secret Circle and now
we're getting back into production so
I'm really focusing on that right now
I've just shot two films since the wrap
of Secret Circle one called snap I'm one
called squatter's both of them I'm
really excited about and I have another
film called the good lie that's supposed
to be in the Toronto Film Festival this
year and I'm shooting a very secretive
one hopefully in August I think but
we'll see on that one but hopefully I'd
love to get the Walk of Fame my film
back up on the ground
you mentioned a very secretive film
there can you give us any hints as to
what genre or is it based on anything a
book or anything not based on a book no
it's it's just that um it's a great kind
of edgy it's an edgy pretty dark film
which seems to be what I keep getting a
cast in both these last ones were pretty
dark as well but it's it's a pretty big
movie and they don't permit you to
discuss these things early on it's not
the two that you can talk about what did
he mention didn't ye and the other movie
that you filmed recently was snap snap
is a jake hoffman Dustin Hoffman's son
and Nikki Reed and I and Scott Bakula
and Jason Priestley and it's a kind of
it's a psycho drama about a young
dubstep musician in LA who's slowly
going mad basically but and I won't say
too much more about that because it's
too fun and then squatters is about
myself and another female homeless
vagrant played by Gabriella Wilde from
London and we're both living on Venice
Beach homeless and we ended up breaking
into this mansion and and living there
for a bit until the family comes home
and it's also with Richard Dreyfuss and
Lolita Davidovich and Luke Grimes and
I'm really excited about the film we
just wrapped a couple weeks ago and it
felt it had that very electric feeling
so I'm hoping it'll be great you
mentioned of course you do lots of pot
of dark rose he hasn't so standard it's
what I haven't used and comedy yeah I
just did right before I came to London I
just did a show with second city which
is a really popular comedy group in Los
Angeles New York and Toronto and now I'm
curious about the idea of doing trying
stand-up just because I think it's the
ultimate challenge to throw yourself to
the woods to the woods to the wolves
it's you know these comedians who do it
again and again and risk you know being
booed or not being funny I think it's
kind of a life-changing attempt to do
that so I'm gonna try we'll see we'll
see I might fall flat on my face but
that's kind of part of the plan too well
I look forward to saying that and good
luck with your movie squatters and snap
yeah will do and also good luck we've
got a secret filming you're doing thank
you
you